تنفي حكومة منطقة شينجيانغ الصينية
مزاعم التعقيم الإجباري التي
فُرضت على
عرقية الأويغور ، يأتي الرد
بعد أسابيع من بث تقرير CNN في 31 يوليو
لتوثيق حملة الاعتداء على
النساء من
الأقليات العرقية المسلمة في شينجيانغ ، وهي منطقة
اتُهمت فيها السلطات بارتكاب جرائم.
وضع مئات الآلاف من الأويغور
في معسكرات الاعتقال حيث أفاد إيفان واتسون
أن حكومة شينجيانغ
أكدت تقارير CNN
بأن هناك انخفاضًا واضحًا مؤخرًا
في معدلات المواليد
في المنطقة بعد أسابيع من بث CNN
تقريرًا في 31 يوليو
يوضح بالتفصيل نمط الانتهاكات ضد
الأويغور  النساء
في شينجيانغ ، أرسلت حكومة شينجيانغ الإقليمية
إلى CNN
هذه الاستجابة المكونة من ست صفحات ، وهي لا
تتحدى ولا تنكر
إحصاءات الحكومة الصينية
التي نشرتها CNN
والتي توثق الارتفاع الأخير في
إجراءات التعقيم
وزرع أجهزة IUD بدلاً من ذلك
تؤكد حكومة شينجيانغ أن
معدل المواليد في المنطقة
انخفض فجأة بمقدار  المركز الثالث في المنتجع الصحي  n
من عام واحد
من 2017 إلى 2018. وتصف الحكومة
هذه
النتيجة بأنها نتيجة رائعة
لتطبيق أفضل لسياسات تنظيم الأسرة في البلاد
مدعية أن عدد الأشخاص
الذين يختارون طواعية
تلقي ربط البوق والجهاز داخل الرحم
قد زاد إلى حد كبير
تقول الحكومة في
انخفض عدد المواليد الجدد في عام 2018
بنحو مائة
وعشرين ألفًا مقارنة بعام 2017.
هاجمت حكومة شينجيانغ
الأكاديمي أدريان زينز
الذي كشف لأول مرة عن الارتفاع المفاجئ في
إجراءات التعقيم في شينجيانغ
باستخدام إحصائيات الحكومة الصينية التي
تدعي الحكومة أن
جميع عمليات التعقيم هذه كانت
طوعية وتتهم زينز  من اختلاق الأكاذيب ،
يقول زن إن الحكومة تلجأ إلى
الهجمات الشخصية
لأنها لا تستطيع أن تعارض بحثه
، هاجمت حكومة شينجيانغ أيضًا
شهادة زومرات داود من الأويغور العرقي من
شينجيانغ التي قالت لـ CNN
إنها أُجبرت على الخضوع لربط البوق
، وتقول حكومة شينجيانغ إن
كانت إجراءات التعقيم طوعية ،
مضيفة أنها وقعت على استمارة موافقة ،
لكن داود يقول إن
المسؤولين الصينيين هددوا
بمصادرة جواز سفرها
وإلغاء تأشيرة زوجها الباكستاني
إلى الصين
إذا لم تخضع
لإجراءات التعقيم في
النهاية ، أكدت حكومة شينجيانغ
تقرير CNN بأن جولبهار
جليلافا مواطنة.  من كازاخستان
تم اعتقالها للاشتباه في قيامها بمساعدة
أنشطة إرهابية
لأكثر من 15 شهرًا قبل
إطلاق سراحها
دون تفسير ،
وتنفي الحكومة مزاعم جاليلافا
بأنها تعرضت للتعذيب والاعتداء الجنسي.
تحملت أثناء
الاحتجاز محنة تقول إنها تركتها مصابة
بالقروح في
جسدها بعد شهور من إطلاق سراحها ،
كررت حكومة شينجيانغ أيضًا حجة
استخدمها
المسؤولون الصينيون لتبرير انخفاض معدل المواليد
في المنطقة
لعقود من الزمان ، وهم يجادلون بالأقليات العرقية
مثل يو.
سُمح للإيغور بإنجاب عدد أكبر من الأطفال مقارنة
بأغلبية هان في الصين
بموجب نظام الحصص الصارم في البلاد
والذي تغير في عام 2016. وقد
تم الآن إصلاح هذا الخلل في التوازن ، كما
تقول حكومة شينجيانغ ،
حيث إنها تقتبس من تنفيذ
سياسة تنظيم الأسرة وفقًا
للقانون
لكن النقاد يقولون إن الزيادة  في عمليات
التعقيم ومواضع iud
يمكن أن تفي بتعريف الأمم المتحدة
للإبادة الجماعية والذي يتضمن فرض
تدابير تهدف إلى منع
المواليد التي تستهدف مجموعة
عرقية أو
دينية قومية ، وهو اتهام تنفيه
حكومة شينجيانغ
بشدة إيفان واتسون cnn
hong kong